- Have a seat.
- Love seeing you.
- So, you were- he was just
sitting here the other day,
- That's right.
- because he hosted for me.
I was so sick.
And you did such a great job.
- Oh, thank you so much.
- And obviously, you did a great job,
you're a host. But I just mean, like,
it's awkward, probably,
to step into, like,
another environment with
another team, and my team,
everybody said you're just
so lovely to work with.
- Oh, thank you.
I had such a great time.
Thank you for- Oh, this's a
little video I did right there.
Well, you know I love you,
and your team is awesome.
The audience is awesome.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] Great energy.
- Your band is great.
However, I was a little
disappointed about one thing.
- Okay, what? We will do better.
- I wish I could have done my Marioke.
- [Kelly] Oh. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- That's the only thing
I was- I had my set list.
I was ready.
- You should have told
us. We would've done that.
- Next one, next one, next time.
- I was like, we would've done that.
We're coming up on award season,
so do you have a favorite
red carpet moment?
You've done a lot of red carpets, right?
So, any one that sticks out?
- Well, my favorite award show every year
is the Golden Globes,
because it's the first one
of the year, and no one's lost yet.
- Oh. (laughs)
- Right?
- Everyone's in good spirits,
very hopeful.
- Everyone's in a good mood.
- You get to see everyone,
all the big TV stars and the movie stars,
but,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
You don't know necessarily
who's gonna win because,
by the time the Oscars comes out,
everyone kind of has an
idea of who's going to win
best actor or best-
- Yeah.
- Right?
But everybody's in a good mood
right there.
- Yeah.
- And I used to have a tradition that-
everybody was ready to party too,
because this is the first
one kicking off the year,
that I'd bring tequila on the red carpet,
and I'd be doing shots
with whoever wanted to do one.
- [Kelly] Yes.
(audience laughing)
Well, listen, I can hold my
tequila, but after a while,
- I've never had someone do
that for me on a red carpet.
- [Mario] Oh my-
- I might do red carpets
if that were happening.
- I remember one time, Kelly,
I was, like, in double digits,
and I was still holding it,
but then I was talking to Reese
Witherspoon and I was, like,
I was maybe a little too close, and this-
And she was getting the
biggest kick outta it, I said,
I stopped myself, "I said,
oh my God, no more tequila."
- Double digits?
- [Mario] I got-
- You're a real man.
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- I can't do that.
- I'm a real Mexican.
(audience laughs)
- I was like, I'm Texan,
I like tequila too, but I-
I would be on the floor
- Yeah.
- with double digits.
It would be a different- I'd
be interviewing like this.
(Mario laughs)
They would never allow me to do that.
- It was fun, but now as you get older,
you know, I gotta keep
it in check a little bit.
- Oh my gosh.
- It does sound fun, though.
- [Mario] Yeah, it's a good time.
- 'Cause sometimes, you know,
people get the same questions,
you know?
- [Mario] Right.
- We often have to ask the same thing.
So it's like,
it's nice when something
breaks it up like that.
- Yeah.
- That's fun.
- Yeah, so that's
probably my favorite time.
- Oh my god. (laughs)
That's- okay, so during the holidays,
your wife posted a photo of an ornament,
and the photo, it says
Baby's 1st Christmas,
so is there something,
like, what's happening?
- Well, that's not my baby!
That's-
(audience laughs)
That's a stock photo of the ornament,
and she forgot to take it out. (laughs)
So then we just gotta roll with it.
And we have three beautiful healthy kids.
And then-
- [Kelly] Please tell me
you're keeping the ornament.
- We've got four now.
- Now we gotta keep it.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- Now we gotta keep it, so.
- Some stranger's baby on your tree.
- Exactly.
- Aww.
- Exactly. Show how much.
- Are you gonna have anymore?
'Cause y'all love your kids,
You love having-
- [Mario] I love-
- There's three, right? So you're-
We have three.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- A girl and two boys.
And I, you know, at that point I was like,
"let's go for four."
My sister has four.
There's the gang right there.
That's what, over Thanks-
that was actually Thanksgiving dinner.
And we didn't have it at
home, because our family
rode the turkey,
Tom the Turkey,
the float for the Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade.
- [Kelly] Oh, yes! Yes.
- Yeah, so we're kind of
leading the charge in there.
So we had to go have Thanksgiving dinner
at a restaurant.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
But my third one turned
out to be a maniac.
And he's-
- Yeah,
- He's broken TVs, he's just real wild.
If he was a little bit more chilled out,
I probably could have
squeezed out a fourth,
But I think she's tapping out.
- You could've squeezed
out a fourth? (laughs)
- Pardon me.
She could've squeezed out a fourth.
I know I could've squeezed out-
Pardon me. She could've.
- Miracles are happening.
No, that's a lot of kids, especially-
Yeah, maybe if he would've
been a little more tamed.
- [Mario] Right, right.
- Yeah.
It would've been a different scenario.
- A different scenario.
- Boys, though, y'all.
Y'all are wild.
- Yeah. Yes.
- My-
Because I have a boy and a girl.
My boy- I'm just like, "you
can't write on the walls!"
- No, right. And then you
get two boys together,
so the brother is just-
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- They're wrestling,
- [Kelly] It's like they're-
Yeah, in competition to see
- Right.
- [Kelly] who can get in trouble the most,
probably. Yeah.
- Yeah.
It's a whole thing, it's-
- Three is good.
(audience laughs)
So you and your wife often work together.
Is this fun?
To do?
- It is fun.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's fun.
You know, I love many
things about my wife, but,
one of the things
- [Kelly] That's good.
- I love is that,
she's funny. She has a quick
sense of humor and, I just-
That make- we connect a lot,
and I think couples
that can laugh together,
it's a healthy relationship,
- Yeah.
Right? So we do a radio show.
I have a nationally syndicated radio show
for IHeartRadio called-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
You've been lucky enough to be on it.
I know, I was gonna say-
- Good times.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- That's right.
Called ON With Mario,
and she's the co-host.
She only comes in, though,
a couple times a week.
'Cause anytime more than that,
we probably have problems.
(laughs) So it's healthy,
you know what I mean?
- Yes.
- A couple times-
But we bank a lot of
the stuff on the show,
and they were auditioning
different females for that role,
for that host position.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
But the audience didn't
like when the other-
the female hosts were sort of teasing me,
or giving me a hard time.
They didn't respond well,
but for some reason,
they love when my wife
gave me a hard time.
(audience laughs)
So they said, how-
- Well, of course, yeah.
Well, it's also a little
behind the scenes too, like,
into y'all- That's nice too.
- [Mario] Yeah. Yeah.
- And it's cool-
Not everybody is down to
be that kind of personality
to be comfortable in that environment.
It's awesome that you're both comfortable.
Yeah.
- Exactly, so yeah.
So, work there, and then
over on Access Hollywood,
and Access Daily, we share the stage
'cause she works on E! News now, too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And everything is great,
'cause it's geographically
very convenient to the house. (laughs)
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- Able to still get the kids-
- When you have kids,
- and all the things going on
- [Mario] Oh yeah.
with their lives, 'cause our lives revolve
around their social calendars-
And they've got very busy schedules,
All the kids, they all sing
and dance, play the piano.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
They're into gymnastics,
jiu-jitsu,
- [Kelly] jiu-jitsu, yeah.
- Wrestling, the whole deal, so-
it's a packed schedule.
- Good. Keep him busy.
- Keep him busy, keep him outta trouble.
- Can't get in trouble.
Yeah. I'm like, that's what my mom did.
- Yeah, that was my mom's plan too.
- This week, we are focusing
on self-care for the new year.
So what are you doing for you this year?
- This is a big year, Kelly.
This year, I'm hitting the fifth level.
I'm turning 50.
- (gasps) You- You know what?
(audience murmurs)
- Turning 50. Ooh.
(audience applauds)
Wow. Hold on a second.
Y'all said "ooh" like that's-
(audience laughs)
Like, I mean, I-
- You know why?
- I don't have a choice!
(audience laughs)
- Do you know why?
- That's it!
- We're all mad, Mario.
- [Mario] What do you mean?
- You don't look 50!
- Oh, you're so nice.
- I wanna call you a name
(audience cheers)
I can't say on daytime right now, like-
- What do you wanna call me?
- An (censored), like- (laughs)
Like, I'm like, you don't look 50,
I'm very upset about it
right now.
- Oh, that's very nice.
We look the same age, and
I just turned 40, whatever.
So,
- [Mario] No, you're-
Here's the thing, though.
- It's fine.
- You know what's crazy, like,
you can't lie about your age anymore.
- Yeah.
- Because they can just
Google you.
- I don't really care.
Yeah.
- No, I don't care either.
- I don't really care, 'cause number one,
you can't really do anything about it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And number two,
you'll get busted, 'cause people can just
Google you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I'm just kind of leaning into it.
I feel good.
I still got a lot of energy.
There are some things, though, like,
back in the day, I used
to be able to party,
hang out.
- Oh.
Get up, work out, I feel good.
Now, I tell my friends,
"yo, you got one night.
Either Friday or Saturday,
- [Kelly] Yeah. (laughs)
- we'll go hard one night, that's it.
And then I'm gonna need the
rest of the week to recover."
- Yeah. Oh, you're better than me.
I can't.
- [Mario] You can't even go?
- No, I mean I go, like,
(audience laughs)
maybe, like, I don't
know, the band'll tell-
We get together, like, maybe
once every three months
or something. (laughs)
- Oh, right, okay.
- I'm, like, tired.
- Yes.
- Yes, there's-
- Sleep is so underrated.
- Ah!
- God, I love it.
- It's a beautiful thing.
- [Mario] I probably sleep
with a smile on my face.
- [Kelly] Yes!
(audience laughs)
- 'Cause it's so-
- [Kelly] Yes.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah. So wait, you were talking
about your kiddos earlier.
We were talking about them.
So, your nine year old Dominic, so,
he has his own show,
and I have to show y'all the-
It's called the Flopez Show.
(Mario laughs)
- It's so funny that you're
giving him a shout-out.
- I know, because-
- He's gonna love this.
- He's so good and cute and
I wanted to squeeze him.
I wanna show you a clip.
- [Mario] And- okay.
This is a clip of the Flopez show.
- Hi guys, welcome back
to the Flopez Show.
So I did a tournament
today, and it was great.
I got third place.
My mom, my dad and all my
coaches are really proud of me.
First match, I'll be honest,
I was pretty disappointed in myself.
I made some simple mistakes
and I lost the match.
But then Donny helped me to
not do the mistakes again,
and it worked.
- [Mario] Ah.
- You guys,
- [Mario] So it's-
- You have to watch the whole thing.
- So it's called the Flopez Show
because Donny is his wrestling coach.
Donny Flowers and then Flo,
and then Lopez the rest.
So he talks about, like,
lessons he learned,
and he talks about
wrestling, and his jiu-jitsu,
and in school and stuff.
And it's just his little, he goes, "Dad,
I think I'm gonna do a YouTube show."
I go, "All right." (laughs)
- Oh my gosh.
Like, it's- And do you feel,
like- if my kid doesn't-
I would feel like such a great parent.
Even how he talks about
learning a lesson, and like,
I was like, you should write a book, like-
- Oh, so sweet.
That's one of the things
I love about martial arts,
and wrestling.
It really- It teaches
you discipline, respect,
a lot of confidence.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Obviously, you're being
tough, but both mentally,
emotionally, sort of
tough, and so it's just-
it's great traits that
you need just in life.
- Yeah. So he- you're into
jiu-jitsu as well, right?
- [Mario] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I kind of got into it
because of him, 'cause I had-
I wanted to put my boys into something,
'cause they were starting
to be hyper like me.
And then, I thought I was
too old to get into it,
'cause I used to wrestle.
- [Kelly] You're never too old
to do anything.
- That's what- thank you.
So that's what I thought.
And then I used to
wrestle back in the day,
and then I got into it, and
then I fell in love with it.
Oh yeah, I just got my purple belt.
- Wait, purple belt's pretty big.
- Yeah, it's cool, yeah.
(audience applauds)
There's just two more belts
after that, right? Yeah.
- Right. The brown belt and black belt.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I love everything about it, Kelly,
because it's like physical chess,
and it's problem solving,
and you're constantly
learning and growing.
It's a lot easier on my body.
'Cause like, I still box.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The body's- boxing's a
little bit more explosive,
so,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I kinda always need that outlet.
So after I've done that,
after you've done getting choked out,
the rest of the day is easy.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Can I learn a move?
I wanna learn a jiu-jitsu move.
Oh, totally! Okay.
- Okay, what's a jiu-jitsu move?
- All right, let's see.
- Okay.
- We won't do any tosses,
- We'll do, like, a simple
rear naked choke, right?
So if you ever-
- Okay. Did you say-
A what?
- A rear naked choke-
Oh, it's got kind of a naughty name to it.
- Okay.
- So you'll go behind here,
- He's very close to me
while saying the word naked.
- Yes. Yes. It's very intimate right here.
- Just saying.
- You'll go behind here,
you'll grab, like, your body-
- I think I've had this dream.
Okay.
(audience laughs)
- Put your hand behind this hair,
- Okay.
and then you start to squeeze
a little bit like that,
and then it starts to hurt.
- And it really works!
- Yeah. When it starts
to hurt, you tap out.
Okay?
- Okay. Tap.
- Yeah, you tap out.
- So wait, I'm not tall enough.
- Yeah, I'll go down here.
- Okay.
So you squeeze-
- Oh, but-
Are you right-handed?
- Yes.
- Okay, go with your left hand.
- Oh, okay. Okay.
Interesting.
So you do that?
I don't wanna hurt you.
You're not gonna- no, I'll tap.
- Okay.
Like that?
Put your right hand behind.
- Right hand.
- Yeah, put- no, grab this.
- Grab this.
- No, this hand grabs that bicep.
- Oh!
- Yeah, now put this behind my head.
- [Producer] We can't hear his mic.
- I-
- Oh, you can't?
- Well, great, I can't hear (censored).
Okay.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers)
- Okay, let go.
- I can't even reach-
I- oh my God.
Do you know what, I literally-
I had-
- No, but that was effective.
Like, you can-
- I had-
- Next time a guy's outta line with you,
you can put 'em to sleep.
- I have abnormally- I'll just
aim for the (censored), man.
(audience laughs)
- Then he'll get down,
and then you got him.
- I have abnormally- You just
found something out about me,
I have abnormally short arms.
They are, they're, like, abnormally short.
So I was like, I can't even
reach my other- it's fine.
I was like-
- So funny.
- I love, every time I have you on here,
we're always doing some kind of activity.
Last time, it was with
your daughter, right?
We were doing the dancing.
- Right, we were dancing.
- Every time, we have to do an activity.